I'm Asian Cuff Generation.
Thank you very much.
[Music]
First of all, please introduce yourself. Please
include the origin of the band name and the cost of forming the band. I'm
Asian Cuff Generation. I'm Kita, the guitar
player. Thank you.
Vocalist.  I'm talking about the guitar, Yamada
is the bassist, and I'm talking about the drums.The origin of the band's name and its formation.I
thought about the name of the band before we formed it.If we were to form a band with only one person,
this would be the name of the band.  Well, at that
time I was into Western studies and I
loved foreign music, so
my dream was really amazing.It
's not an ancient delusion, but I'd
like to perform overseas someday, outside of Japan.  I
felt like we were going to play,
so I thought it would be a good idea to write to the band that our identity is
that we are Asians, and it would be
great if we could just make fun of them.  At
that time, I was really into
Jackie Chee movies and those Bruce
Three movies, and I put "Kunfu" in the cuff movie.
Generation was already on its way,
right?
When we first teamed up.  Man's name was already decided,
so we first formed a team here.The
day before Kita-kun ambushed me in the university courtyard in the middle of the night, we met up with friends from the
light music club, or rather, the club.
At one of our gatherings, we talked about forming a band for the Union Army,
but the next day, he
came out of the darkness in the university courtyard and
told me yesterday that he had said he was going to form a band.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I never thought it would
last this long.At that time, I
felt like I was going to
sleep, right?That's right, I was waiting.The way I was waiting was in the middle of the night.In the middle of the night, in the middle of the night.No, it was
already dark that evening, and I was
at the university at night.  I was back home, so yeah, that's right. I was
scared, so I invited Nemu-chan.
Nemu and I were in the same circle.
Three years later, we intervened, and now we're all together. It's
been over 25 years since the band was formed,
but from that time.
What kind of efforts are you making to deal with both fans and new fans? I guess it's
not about the order of things, but rather the fact that you don't discriminate between the two.  Is it
okay to say yes to people who have recently fallen in love with us? It's
not that there's any difference, it's just that they like our music right now. That's
right. The timing of when they fell in love with us is always welcome.
Yes, yes, right now,
whether it's at a concert or
in front of a screen, we feel like we're
just friends who share this feeling, this sound, etc.  Because
I have it,
in other words, I don't judge it by whether it's old or new.I
feel like if I were to say what the question asked, it would be an answer to the picture.Yes,
everyone's works.  It has a variety of music genres,
90's alt rock, indie,
rock pop punk, etc.
What is your favorite music genre? Is there any new
genre you would like to try?
Everyone is different, so
how about something like Kiyoshi?  What is my favorite Jeanne, and what new
Jeanne would I
like to try? What I've always loved is metal. I
love metal, so I started a band playing metal.
So recently, I've only recently joined academia, and I've
been thinking about guitar rock.  Yeah, I'd like to do something
a little more like dance rock in the future.I'm a bit
confused by this sudden confession, but even if I could do dance rock, I'm sure.When I
hear about what's being streamed...  I
tend to choose alternative music from among genres, and I
often find myself relistening to the music I listened to the most in the 90s or when I first started listening.
Yeah, yeah, it's my
favorite journal. There's a lot of different things,
right now, but rap music is
interesting after all. I wonder what bits are
popular. Yeah, I
listen to a lot of Latin music. Yeah, it feels like it's from other countries. Yeah, I
like a lot of music.  There are
some Japanese folk songs that are good and old, but yeah,
we all discuss what we want to do, so I
can't declare it as dance rock here.Well, I don't know what to say,
but I also
like this kind of thing.  I really
liked indie rock, right?
Indie rock is good. There
might be a lot of US indie music, I'm sure.
But what I'd like to try is something like this,
like the teacher who came out with dance rock a while ago, and the members like this.  If someone says, "I've tried this," I want to
follow it,
and I
'm always looking for what's good about it,
but I guess that's just how it is.  You
have appeared at many festivals and live shows, such as Weezer Festival 7 Mugen Festival, which you
guys are hosting, but what kind of role have live performances played in your activities?
When people ask me about this, they often
start talking about numbers, and then they start talking about where it sold, where it was sold, the charts,
or even how much people listen to it in what country,
but somehow I
can see their faces.  Yes, I'm worried that I
can't see the faces of those people,
or rather, I'm hearing such numbers.But when I
perform live, there are actually people there.For
example, when I go to Brazil, there are people there.
Well, I don't know if I'll go there again. I'd
go to a port city like Fortaleza in Brazil, but it would seem like there were people there actually waiting for us. What do you
really mean when you say something like that?  It gives
us energy that we can use to go back to searching for the cats,
so maybe
people want to see us and
come to the concert, but
for us, it's a
place where we can really get energy.  Well,
it's a special place
because it's a place where you can see the fans who trust you, and you really feel like they're alive,
but I was really moved by it.They're probably
going to South America or something, right?Where are you going?  Even when I
go to Asia, I'm still impressed. That's why I
have so many fans. It
seems like there's a lot of information that I didn't know about through Facebook or anything like that. I
get emails and things like that. I
actually stand on stage like this.  I mean, it
was amazing. Yes, I thought it was true. It was
moving, and I'm
so happy. Out of all the tours you've been on,
is there a favorite one? Do you have any
plans for future overseas tours?  Please tell me your
favorite tour.The
first tour I went on
was a European tour that visited about 4 countries.I
still forget the scenery I saw in London.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, and I was surprised to see so many people in Paris. In
2015, I
went to Europe and then
went straight to South America
for about two weeks.  I have great memories of the tours we went on, yes, yes, yes, it's
true, but about two
years later, we were given a tour of North America and South America, and there were
many other things that happened, so any
place was good, but I
was able to go overseas.  It's been a great motivation for me in my band activities, to work hard
so that I can go overseas again, and it's
also a great motivation for me to write songs.Yeah,
you guys have had successive hits like Naruto, Bleach, Fullmetal Alchemist Surplus,
Semi-Mythology, etc.  They are a pioneer whose
opening and ending songs have
had a big impact on overseas anime fans.Did you
expect that you would have so many fans overseas when you created these songs
?  Even though it was made at the time,
when I was doing the theme song for Naruto, Haruka Kanata, I was like, oh
yeah, when I talked to the Sony director, it was
really meaningful to be able to do the opening for Naruto.  I
remember talking about how we might be able to go out into the world with this anime, and
yeah, yeah, it's
true, it's a ninja anime, so
yeah, I thought it was very Japanese and interesting.  I
thought it would become popular overseas, but I never
thought it would get this far.It
feels like it has a different power to it no matter where you go.  It's really
interesting to hear people say that it's such a great anime, or rather, it's such a great work.In fact, when I hear about
recent works, I feel like I'm getting a lot of attention from
overseas.  I'm conscious of that a little bit,
I guess, and it
influences the songwriting a little bit.
When I do a Naruto song, I wonder if I should say something like that. It
seems like it has a
ninja feel.  I think we
should choose as many oriental influences as possible, and I
think it would be good to use a somewhat deformed Japanese melody, like YMO did in the past.  I
think about things like guitar phrases, and when I do that, I'm really
happy when they sing it live, but it's a big influence on my
songwriting. I'm sure
you've all seen Bocchi the Rock.
The title is
based on your song, and the last names of the characters are also
based on everyone's names.It
has something to do with the manga and anime series, aka
Bocchi the Rock.Especially
from us, but we're really
happy.  I mean, I was surprised.
Yeah, it's already popular overseas. Yeah,
that's right. Yeah, that's right. We
spent our student lives
in a place called Kanazawa Hakkei. Yes, we really
lived in Yokohama.  It seems like he's been to the eight scenic spots of Kanazawa in the area of ​​New York,
Shimokitazawa in Tokyo, and other islands.The
depictions of Kamakura are quite
familiar, so it was really
fun to watch.  I wonder if the background of the animation is
quite realistic and the scenery is pretty realistic.The
characters are the same as ours.I don't know if the characters with our last names are our
personalities or not.Yama-
chan
is kind of a cool character,
yeah.  Yeah, I'm really like that.
What's that? I'm a bright girl. Yeah, there's a
character. Yamada-chan is eating right now. That's
a bit like that. He
looks like he's been praised.
Isn't it Yamada-san who was praising you?  Yeah,
yeah, yeah, they're cool characters, but I don't think the
author had
a bit of an image in mind when creating them, and I
don't think there's a connection between
them.
You know they've had a huge influence on metalcore bands,
Bad Omens Alpha Wolf,
Archetype,
Colliburgmans, they're
pretty famous, sorry, I'm
crazy.  Perhaps because of my
chemical romance or yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah, it's
like that, but
the thing that I used to hear about this in the past is ah ah I
entered the Thundercat playlist.
Haruka was on my playlist. I was
a bit surprised. I've
heard a lot of stories like that over the years, and it's
amazing.
Anyone who loves this kind of hard, metal, core-pando music would be happy. Even if you're
not a musician, you'd be happy.  That's right. I'm
really happy that you've fallen in love with me and given me the opportunity to start making something. But when it comes to metal, we don't really
think of ourselves as metallic, so it's
surprising, but it's kind of
interesting.  There's
a little bit of a heavy Yamachan's
bass line in the music, and it may be a bit of a bit of a bit of a
music.  I made a
complete version of the Saff Literature Kamakura album that I made in 2000. There
's that Japanese railway called Enoshima
Dentetsu, which has 15 stations, and
10 of them were used as songs.  In 2008, I
wrote the songs for the remaining 5 stations, and released an album with all 15 stations
this summer, so I'd be happy if you could
listen to it again on various distribution services.It's a
power pop song similar to the likes of Weezer.  It's an album,
right? So maybe there's a
little bit of ``90s American alterity that people can play with, and there's
a lot of homages sprinkled in. So,
please give it a listen.
[Music]
From now on, I'll ask each person one question at a time.  I'm
asking you to answer in one word in the same format, so let's
do it in this order.Okay, let's go.Free, let's go.Okay,
now
what's the first song on your favorite playlist?Um, Metallica.
Yeah, yeah, 72 Seasons, then Emma.
Well, I
often
listen to the song ``Any Time of Day'' by The Lemons.It's not the first song, but
yes, this is what I think.That's the case with me, then Annie.I wonder if it's the
IT mass change.Oh, everyone.
Right now, the Foo
Fighters' song Under You is
on my favorite playlist.
Are there any songs or artists that I'm secretly into
? I've been really into Corrigon lately.  Coming to Fujiroku
Hey, Mr.
Unyama, what are you talking about? It's
an artist called Beabadoobee. I wasn't able to
see Viva last year because Summer Sonic was on a different day, but
I've always wanted to see them live. Yeah, yeah, me and Kuku are Beabadoobee. I
like their recent songs.  Yeah, it's a very slow song,
yeah, it's really good, it's amazing, and I
think vivado is good, yeah, it's the best. I was
just making a power pop album, so do you have any
plans when you cook?  I
want to enjoy homemade cooking. I like up-tempo music.
WKW I don't want to say it's nostalgic or nostalgic. I've
heard that you've been cooking lately. Hey, I
don't listen to cooking, but I don't listen to songs that I want to listen to. It's okay,
cooking.  If you're going to do this, you'll have to eat something like this,
Kamakura Hoa. What do you think of our own sweets?I don't
listen to them either, but I
often listen to my own humming.It's
the same with me.I don't cook much,
but I often do.  At home, I was just humming along. That's right.
Gotchi sent me this demo, and
then I
started singing the melody he gave me, trying to figure out if I could understand it a little, and
coming up with guitar phrases and things like that.  I guess it's
quite popular at home, surprisingly.Yes,
yes, I do have a favorite anime.I
have many favorite anime, but the
first thing that comes to mind is Dragon Ball, which
is generational.
Gundam's first series,
First Gundam, First Gundam.
I
mean, space, space, space, that's it, Japan, it was
being played all over the country, I do
n't know, it's not just Shizuoka.The
theme song is the best.  It's
so good sometimes, if
I and I
searched for it on YouTube, everyone would be able to listen to it.Oh yeah, it's
great to be selected for a dream performance.For me, I
loved it when I was little.Captain
Pa also played soccer with that one.
Yes, I've already given up on this, but
even though it's soccer, if I could collaborate with anyone,
which artist would I want to collaborate with? I wonder if there is any,
but I still
want Dave Grohl to produce it with Fighters Nenepu.
Maybe Wirtz-kun, Wurtz-kun, you're a Japanese
artist. It seems like it's a collaboration between a young artist. Hey, yeah, maybe
that'll come true. Maybe it'll happen.
I'll never be able to express myself in a book anymore,
but I really regret it.  One of the things that remains
is that Hajime Sakamoto passed away, and we were
pretty close to him, but we were able to
create music together, and that's
right, we sampled Sakamoto's songs and
became a rapper.  I made something with him, but
he said he wanted to do something outside or improvise together.Well, I'll
ask him about that.I
might have wanted to, but that's a bit.If it
really happened, I'd like to try it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I can't think of any collaborations, but there are
quite a few studios I'd like to go to, like
Rockfield Studio on a farm in Wales, England, and I'd like to record something like this someday.
Lastly, do you have a routine that you always do before a concert? It
could be a personal thing or a personal thing, but now we're all doing this, we're all doing this, we're doing this, we're doing this, we're doing this, we're going to do this, we're going to do this, we're going to do this.
That's what I do before a live performance.This is the one that I want to give me
a word of the day and give a speech.It's a
personal thing.I go to the bathroom.  There's
no one out there who doesn't go for a routine. What are you doing
? You're wearing that scent. It looks like you
can do it. It's called Dilux. It's called
Hi-
Potential Oil. It's not a suspicious name. I
see, people from all over the world were singing Hi-Pot during the live show.  I thought you were
laughing, it's High Potential
Potential Oil. I see the name.
Neya-chan is right. I guess the one thing I
don't miss is my wristband. Ah, I see. I
always wear a wristband. I do
n't miss my power stones either.
If
I don't do this, I get a little anxious.I'm stretching.I'm stretching.I'm stretching.I
don't know if you're listening or not, but I'm
drinking an energy drink like this.  I'm
trying my best to become what I heard.Every time
[Music]
Yes, when I have a question about a member, I have a
question, so I point to the right person.I point to the right
person.Yes, I'm going to do my best.Yo,
yes, the member who is not good at getting up early is Seinominami.  I wonder
who I am even if
I'm like that one.In reality, I've
been doing that lately.It used to be me.But in
recent years, I've stopped drinking.On the contrary, I
wake up early, and I'm no longer late.  I guess it
's a big deal because I'm no longer late. Yeah, I've been criticizing
myself just now, but I'm not good at it. Hurry up,
Yama-chan, there's a quick way out. But, you know, I do
n't like it. I
force myself to get up early. I'm trying my best to stay awake now.
Lately, I've been noticeably late. It's been noticeable that
Nake-san is late and I'm the last one to meet up. That's
true. I feel
like I'm finishing up early. I
'm going to be late.  Yeah, I'm becoming an old man,
so I wonder
what's wrong with the members who can't finish their live shows.The
members who don't have a lot of time to finish their live shows.Even if I do
n't understand what that means,
I'll try pointing at it.  It's like he
doesn't show up for the last line. He's like that.
When he's the last headliner at a festival, he always
comes up to the front and greets everyone, but that's me.  It
's always the last one. Yeah, it's true that the last song really pulls on the lingering sound of the last song.
Yeah, it might be this. When I listen to it, I do
n't think I
've done much. Don't do it. It'll bring out what you want.  I'm
sure they're having fun doing it.The sound of that song makes me
want to pull out that arpeggi.It
reminds me of that amazing Radiohead ending.I feel like there's something
left at the end.There's definitely something left at the end.  The
members who tend to forget the parts of the songs are still there. This is quite a difficult part.
Today's episode is also the same as
Manjo Hajime. It's
not that I forget, but it does
change.  Yeah, I get it. I get it. I keep changing. I keep
changing the
same thing. I said that I can't do the same thing over and over again.
Yeah, I forget the lyrics more often than I do. It
seems like I forget lyrics, like
during live performances.  The phrases in Kyushu are different, such as when the song is about to end, and
when it's the 1st verse, it's already on the 2nd verse, and it's not
rusty yet, but it's rusty.  When it comes to
songs in dramas, it's up to
everyone to decide what to do with the
song when I've moved on.Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
half of that tense feeling.I think I can
sing it, but if it's that much, it's
still blank.It's sometimes combined.
We're all so excited, but
in that sense, I'm the one with the most
poca.Next, who's the picky member?
Who's the picky member?Ayama-chan, who's going to go, is
my 2 votes.  2 votes Who is Yama-chan? Is it
Terugo-yama-chan? Is
this Yama-chan? Yes, yes,
this is what I eat here. Mona members. Well, I don't know right now, but lately I've been getting the image of people saying, ``I want to eat that, I want to eat this.''  I
feel like there are a lot of times when I have a clear idea of ​​what I want to eat at Gocchi.No, that's
not the case.Maybe that's the case,
but it's
not like I can eat that much.  Yeah, that's right, that's right, that's right, that's right, that's right, that's right, that's right, that's right, that's right, that's right, that's right, that's right, that's right.
Yes, this is already Nemine, this is Nemine.
Thank you so much Nemine. As
Nesaki said earlier, I have certainly been
listening to music from many different countries. Lately, I have had more opportunities to listen to young Japanese artists.  However, it's
interesting because young people also know a lot about it, because Mogocchi seems to
be doing a lot of supporting for young Japanese musicians. Yeah,
yeah, that's quite true. I want to
do that properly.  I
want to keep making new discoveries of great talent, and since everyone knows so much about foreign music, they
all come together at the end of the year to put out the
best of the year.There are a lot of
times like this that I didn't know about.
You know, there's a lot of
music out there, and I think I was listening to some of the members and other women who know a lot about this kind of music.Oh,
yeah, yeah, that's
right.Surprisingly, the bride was a seasoned bride.In case you didn't know,
I'm quite a seasoned
listener.  I
think it's a good project.Yes, let's go.Next
up is the
best dancer among the members.It's difficult,
isn't it?Dancer Dancer.Ah, yes, I think it's a good idea.Nochanyama-
chan is here.This is that paradox.In a
sense, I don't like that.  The music
video for Hana has a paradoxical meaning to me
right now, because yes, Gocha has done it after all.  It
was really hard to learn,
but I remember that I learned it overnight. I came here at around 3 a.m. and
by morning I had memorized it in a
few hours.  But during live shows,
there are times when I dance a little bit.
Yeah, I want to learn dancing, like pop dancing. It's a
dance that I've always admired. It
might be good for vocalists to dance. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Well
then.  Last question: Members who love to play pranksMembers who love to
play pranks I don't know,
let's go, yes.
Yeah, I
'm laughing when I'm hosting a photo of my artist or a photo of myself
during the interview.
That's right, I'm so
excited, and then during the encore of the Saa concert that we used to do so well,
Unyamu-chan came
out and said, ``I'm alive!'' and Chanda-chan stopped and stopped and did
n't come out.  I don't
really notice it, so I don't think so. That's
funny. Yam-chan is usually
quiet like this, but it's only during her live performances that she
gets a little excited.  It's
not an oil, but it's a
feeling.It's not a potential, so it makes me want to swim.That's right.A little bit may
be a lot.Yes, that's right.I'm not saying yes,
but it's from the Asian cuff
generation.Thank you very much.Thank you
very much.
Music]
Masu